حسن مسعود في كييف المتابعات هناك لكل هذه
التطورات المرتبطه تحديدا بهذا الاستهداف
للمطارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه بكثافه
وباقي التطورات في الجبهات الاخرى
نعم مريم نبدا من هذا الخبر تحديدا حيث
كانت القوات الجويه والمتحدث باسمها قد
اعلن بشكل رسمي استهداف مطار في منطقه
سومي شمال شرقي اوكرانيا واكد ان هذا
الاستهداف تم خلال هجمه ليليه بسته صواريخ
وجهت نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه اثنين من هذه
الصواريخ وجهت نحو منطقه سومى واستهدفت
هذا المطار وتحدث للمره الاولى عن واقع
العمليات الجويه الاوكرانيه قال ان القوات
الجويه تنفذ بشكل متواصل عمليات هجوميه
وغير هجوميه بطائرات
جويه وطائرات حربيه تحديدا اوكرانيه وان
القوات الجويه نفذت خلال اليوم الماضي 30
طلع جويه من بينها نفذت عشر هجمات على
مواقع روسيه وهو ما استدعى هذا الرد بضرب
المطار في منطقه سومي قال انه لن يتحدث عن
الكثير من التفاصيل حول هذه الضربه لاسباب
تكون واضحه بالنسبه للمتابعين لكن بكل
الاحوال فهذا الاعلان ليس اعلانا معتادا
من الجانب الاوكراني عن الضربات التي يمكن
ان تتلقاها في مواقع حساسه مثل هذه في
مطارات معينه وهذا ياتي في ظل سماعنا خلال
الايام الاخيره لتحليق للطائرات
الاوكرانيه في الاجواء الاوكرانيه لاسيما
هنا في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف وتحديدا
خلال اطلاق الصواريخ او الحديث عن اطلاق
صواريخ باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه على ما
يبدو ان طلعات جويه اوكرانيه تنفذ خلال
الضربات الصاروخيه وهذا ايضا ياتي في سياق
الحديث الاوكراني عن الحاجه لاستخدام
الطائرات الحربيه لسيما طائرات اف 16
لاسقاط الصواريخ التي توجه نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه خلال هذه الازمه ايضا كان هناك
هجمه اربعه صواريخ نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كياف لكن الاداره العسكريه تحدثت عن اسقاط
هذه الصواريخ بالاضافه الى اسقاط ثلاثه
مسيرات وجهت نحو العاصمه ايضا فيما تمكنت
مسيرتين من الوصول الى اهدافها دون الحديث
عن تلك الاهداف التي وصلت اليها هذا في
مرتبط بالهجمات على العاصمه وعلى العدد من
المدن والمناطق انما ايضا في ظل استمرار
المعارك في الجبهات المختلفه شرقا وجنوبا
هناك ايضا حديث من جانب ما يسمى بفيلق
قوات
المتطوعين الروس وكذلك فيلق حريه روسيا ان
نفذ هجمات كما ذكر الزميل الامين على
الجانب الاخر قام بعدد من الهجمات في
منطقه بلغرود وكان هناك هذا العرض لحاكم
مقاطعه بولغريد للقاء هناك وكان هناك
تعليق ايضا من الجانب الاوكراني بشكل رسمي
من مستشار الرئيس الذي وصف هذه الهجمات
المتواصله والتي قال انها ستتواصل في
الداخل الروسي بانها ان انتهاء لحكم
لاستقرار حكم بوتين الذي استمر لعشرين
عاما وفق قوله وقال ان هذه الهجمات هي
اشاره ونموذج لما يحدث وسيحدث في الاراضي
الروسيه من فوضى ومن زعزعه للاستقرار وفق
تعبيره شكرا جزيلا لك حسان مسعود منك